tell me a little bit about being a woman
in this space because you have a double
a double-edged sword so to speak here
because leaving a religion any religion
stuff but particularly tough to leave
Islam and then when you couple that with
all the stuff related to being a woman
and being a secular woman in America in
2015 isn't that easy sometimes how does
that play into how you how you live well
let me start by saying there's so many
people that I'm connected to through my
through the organization and through
meeting a bunch of X Muslims I mean I
think I don't think you'd be a stretch
to say that I probably know more X
Muslims than most people you know in the
world you know we'll ever know that and
and what I what I hear consistently from
a lot of women that the reason that they
left the religion was because of the
treatment of women and a lot of it just
didn't make any sense and they didn't
they didn't appreciate they felt that
they weren't being given the same kind
of dignity as as men and when they
looked at it from that perspective
things changed feminism had a lot to do
with it which is very interesting when
you talk about today is feminism here
yeah but really found the feminist
allies in the West that I thought I
would find I expected for them to be the
first people to run to my defense and a
few have but a small few I expected
there to be big valley with you know
feminists from all over to come and talk
about these issues but I haven't found
that to be the case they're always very
disheartening yeah so what is that
strange Alliance because you see this
all the time you know a group like code
pink that stands for women's rights an
anti-war you would think they would be
standing for women's rights all over the
globe but instead they'll rant and rave
and you know talk about Gaza meanwhile
if they ever went to Gaza I'm pretty
sure that these women would not be
treated particularly well so this double
standard just endlessly exists huh yeah
absolutely and I I think it's it's it's
very like I said it's disheartening for
one and because I was somebody that that
feminism was a huge part of me leaving
religion it was a huge part of me of
fueling me and the women's rights causes
of fueling me into my activism it's been
especially painful to see that feminists
are not always on my on the same
me what I have found is that there's a
lot of posts about women that say the
Muslim women that say that they're
empowered by the hijab you know and
there would be they'll be on feminist
websites they'll say you know I'm very
empowered you're just a job and it's my
political whatever and you know it to me
it's it's wonderful for that particular
woman if she feels that this is her
choice and this is what she wants to do
and this is how she wants to live her
life that's great but Muslim women
that's wearing the hijab making a piece
like that is like a woman in you know
1930s America saying that I'm proud to
be a housewife I love staying home with
my children this is exactly where I want
to be well good for you maybe you do and
that's wonderful it's good for you that
everything in society aligned with your
desire perfectly right oh you and now
you get to live this wonderful life but
you have to acknowledge the 1930s
America women who maybe wanted to have a
career weren't as free to do so that
there were so many different factors
that were put making it very very
difficult for them to live the life the
way they wanted to you have to be able
to acknowledge that in that same way I
want these kajabi women to be able to
acknowledge it today there's so many
women who don't ascribe to these modesty
codes and they aren't free to live lives
the way they want yeah well and this
again this is why the left has put
themselves in this regressive left has
put themselves in such a crazy box they
should be defending women's options they
don't have to say you have to live a
certain way but they should at least
give you the options and that's also why
they've been relentless on New Atheists
oh you get it now as a woman you get it
as an ex-muslim I don't know if you
identify specifically with a new atheist
with new atheism you consider yourself a
new atheist I'm not sure nobody nobody
really seems to know the best way I can
describe it now as at least as I've come
to understand it is that it's an atheist
who was finally speaking up so for that
for that version that's what I would
consider myself but but the community
the left really has been attacking
atheists too so your honor like you're
like spinning and you got shot from all
sides huh I I definitely feel that way I
mean I don't want to talk about how big
of a victim I am because I don't like
those
politics but but in general I have felt
that the people that on paper should be
supporting me and I looked into this
actually as a response to seeing the way
that left its I've reacted I've started
do more research on what liberal
principles were and really trying to get
a grounding on what it meant to be a
liberal and I feel and Bill Mara said
this so many times he said I'm the real
liberal and I think he's right he's
right when he says he's a real liberal
and I feel like I'm a real little yeah
so you're not gross and racist that's
what you're telling me Oh God that when
I was watching that I kind of felt I'm
gonna get haters or been a little but I
kind of owe it's cute that he's standing
up he thinks he's standing up for the
poor oppressed minority right that's
what he's doing that's what he's really
convinced that he's standing up for an
oppressed group and it's nice that he
has good intentions but it's nice I
appreciate that but he's so wrong and
he's really hurting the same minorities
and he's not understanding exactly
what's going on here and it was very
interesting in that particular scenario
to see Sam and then very emotional been
asked like very very emotional been
asked like I'm very calm Sam Hearst
you know I think you'll find this
interesting I was discussing this with
first off I discussed it with Sam
himself but I also discussed it with Joe
Rogan a couple weeks ago on his show and
I said what you just said I said well
you know I think he was trying to do the
right thing and trying to and maybe he
got too emotional but you know he was
trying to stand up for the downtrodden
that kind of thing and joe said
something that i now fully believe i
mean he got me to change my opinion like
that he said no he's like man i know
actors I'm around actors they fake this
so that everyone will just think they're
so holy they're so benevolent they're so
wonderful and all that and he was really
convinced that that's what Ben was doing
there but I don't I don't want to waste
any more any more time on that
specifically so the Atheist stuff yeah
you're getting you're getting it from
them you're getting it from the other
guys what can we do then what what can
secular people and free thinkers do
because I know that people just by
listening to this
a certain subset of people are gonna say
all the things that you laid out at the
beginning they're gonna say that I hate
Muslims that you're a secret Zionist all
of this nonsense but what can we do
I guess just talk right I mean it's
really that the best we can do I think
just be intellectually honest and I
think that a lot of people understand
what I mean when I say that because
people stop themselves they want to say
these things they have these opinions
and the reaction that I got to my speech
at the American Humanist Association the
biggest reaction was you said what I
wanted to say yeah you you put the words
that I was thinking in my head but I
just felt like I couldn't
I really couldn't articulate and I felt
trapped and you said those things so it
felt like a release you know for it for
me to hear you say it for to hear
somebody say it and I think that if we
can be brave and if we can talk about it
and especially liberals it is very
important that it is liberals who stand
up for this because we are the
compassionate ones right well that
really are keeping the harm of that of
the people in place we are not
forgetting about anti-muslim bigotry
that is something that is that is
obviously at the forefront of my of our
minds we know that because that's why
we're not saying anything about this
yeah yes it is those particularly those
people that need to be speaking out they
need to be making this nuanced
discussion right and that's what it
seems so obvious to me that I don't have
to twist my beliefs to say the things
that I'm saying to you everything that
I'm saying to you and I sense everything
that you're saying to me is based in the
same set of secular principles that you
apply to everything else and for some
reason these guys want you to just be a
little more careful when it comes to
this set of ideas but what I see is the
real danger there is that if we don't
speak up
right now and and we're at it we're an
extremely precarious moment right now
with everything going on in Paris and
with Isis and all that that if we don't
speak up we hand the future to the
people on the right I think absolutely
there they are getting empowered by this
because people are not stupid we are
seeing that there is this big elephant
in the room that people we cannot talk
about that the media isn't talking about
what are we doing we're building
distrust of your average American
citizen when they're watching their TV
screens and they're not seeing anybody
but
snooze really talking about Islam in a
way that feels remotely honest and and
it's horrible it's horrible that we're
giving this up to these people who
really have some xenophobic motives
maybe you know and we need to make sure
that it is us that are talking about
this that are engaging with this issue
you can it's it's similar to I think
what happened with the Tea Party I think
there was some real hurt and some real
pain right after you know the economic
downturn and I think a lot of people
were feeling abandoned by their
government and I think we could have III
even say now we could have seized on
that moment and we could have made it a
populist progressive movement to take
down you know corporations or whatever
it is we could have we could have
harnessed it but instead we disdain
those people because they were you know
backwater bigots whatever people who
were very uncommon but they don't
understand things in a nuanced
complicated way though the way that
everyone else does and so we find it
very easy to to to just push them aside
and dismiss them and look at what
happened there right they became a
political force that a lot of people
would say have done some harm the
political spectrum so we don't want that
happening again yeah I don't know if you
saw my video about it a couple weeks ago
but I said that the regressive left is
our Tea Party and I don't want what has
happened to the right that has been
dragged off the deep end I don't want
that happening to my side that's why I
do think we're at this moment so I know
we only have a little bit left but I do
want to focus on Paris a little bit I
know you're not you're not a terrorist
expert or something of that nature but
in terms of the human part of this that
it sounds like a lot of these people did
grow up in Paris there or in France they
grew up in the West some of them grew up
in Belgium but they grew up in Western
societies what do you make of that kind
of radicalization because you know I
know a lot of the debate right now is
about can we let refugees in are we
gonna let terrorists in with refugees
and that but there's also a homegrown
problem right now that we're not dealing
with yeah I this is my in just my
opinion and again I'm not a scholar on
this but I feel like there are many
young people in different parts of
Europe especially and I think you're
particularly that feel that they
and a lot of people say they're between
two cultures that's the fray that people
use that they're between this Western
culture and their culture back home but
III don't think that that's the truth I
think that the truth is that they don't
really have any they don't really have
any viable options they don't really
believe in the same stuff that that
their parents might have done from
Pakistan or whatever and they don't
really fit in with the community in in
the West and they sort of feel lost by
this multicultural right that if we can
push and then a lot of people do have
this specific critique they say that we
have lost our bearings we have lost our
values we don't really push our story
and our values and our you know and on
our way of looking at the world we don't
really advocate for that in the way that
it deserves to be advocated for and I
think these are the people that are
there the lost children of because these
are people who don't have anything to
they don't have anything to latch on to
what they do have to latch onto is if
somebody comes and says this Islamist
narrative and everything makes so much
sense and it's everything is so clear
now and they can grapple on to it
I think you've covered this so many
times you talked about this about
freedom of speech issues about how we're
not allowed to talk about certain ideas
I think it's so harmful that we're not
allowed to talk about critique of
religion critique of Islam because we're
then we're giving up this ground to to
the Islamists we're letting them give
these people these these great
narratives that they'll latch on to and
they don't have any opposing narrative
at all yeah so what so what do we do I
mean really what are the secularists do
I know that there are some organizations
like the one that margins involved in
that are trying to Deer addict lies
people show them that there's other outs
and I'm with you I get it that it's it's
a compounding of economic issues and and
religious narrative and imperial it's
all of these things but how do we move
forward because the talking as we're
doing it's good for now
but at some point we got to get to these
to the kids I guess the younger
generation well this is something that's
related to the Syrian refugees that are
coming in a lot of people are very
worried about the effect that these
refugees will have on the countries and
I think the only long-term way of
proceeding and making sure that we don't
have
these same kind of problems is to push
emergent as much as we can which means
that we don't allow them to build these
isolated little communities we spread
them out within within the the country
and we pull them in into the you know
American Way of life or Western Way life
what have you in that sense I think a
lot of these multicultural narratives
are very very very harmful I think we
need to discard them immediately there's
a lot of this there's a lot of hesitancy
we know we know how to pull immigrants
in and how to immerse them into our our
society we know that there's so much
there's someone should work about this
and scholarly is stuff about this
written about this we can do it sure
we're a nation of immigrants right
everybody every one of us every one of
us here in America we either are from
immigrants or we were brought over as
slaves or we're Native Americans but but
the large majority of us are immigrants
and you know what because what happened
was America pulled us in and said well
here's the stuff I don't like but here's
the stuff I do like and they pulled it
together and we became this nation that
is so powerful and then what you have
instead in places like the UK is it
these mini nations that are not a part
of the overall you know Britain's
British society there's a little
Pakistani community and a little North
African community and they sort of lived
as if there are back in Pakistan or
Bangladesh or whatever it is and that I
think is so harmful because these people
never feel like everyone else that I
feel like an American and I don't think
everyone else does and I want them to
feel that way I want them to feel like
an American yeah it's an interesting
it's almost like a self-fulfilling
prophecy because then when when the
British people go in and try and go move
into that community then they feel like
those people in that community feel like
they're under attack or something or
they have to defend their their little
area so you have this constant battle of
you know of the self verse the the
bigger community yeah and what it was
happening that we've given up the battle
right we've just said okay we'll just
live however you want to live you're
just different people and you just
operate on different rules and you
different concepts of human rights and
that's just we're just gonna turn a
blind eye that's what's happened in the
UK I think and we can't do it anymore
right
no we have to have these I mean we've
always had with these immigrant
communities in the United States is
negotiation
he's back in forts within these scuffles
and sometimes they've been very painful
but in the end we're stronger and the
immigrant community gets immersed and is
stronger too
yeah all right so my final thought would
be I've been trying to end all my
conversations on a note of positiveness
and I think you've actually given a lot
of hope throughout here but I definitely
sense that the tide is turning I know it
feels like a dangerous time right now
there's there's so much craziness going
on and with the internet everything
feels smaller so when something happens
5,000 miles away it seems like it
happened in your backyard but I do sense
something good here the fact that we've
connected the fact that all of these
people now that we're all in the same
circles and we're all talking and our
circles are getting bigger I do feel
like maybe the tide will turn in our
favor do you do you feel that give me
something good to end down here I think
I think you're absolutely right you've
mentioned this before I noticed that
things are changing and I feel this I
think Majin was have said it too before
what he said the left is changing and he
feels this you can sort of sense it in
the air that there is discontent there
that there's people where suddenly
there's a lot of dissonance going on
yeah it was mindin we want it to make
sense and I think that we're giving you
know this point of view that we're
giving is one that is so much more clear
and it's so much better for people and
better for Humanity and I think people
will will slowly gravitate towards it
yeah you know it's funny I did a video
on free speech last week and at the end
I referenced you know all of this stuff
was saying safe spaces and trigger
warnings and all this nonsense and it's
like when I speak to someone like you
and I speak to majid and ayaan and Sam
and all these people I said in the video
I was like look guys watch my videos
with these people if you think these are
the extremists then there's something
wrong with you it's not something wrong
with them you know imagine Sam just
wrote a book called the Islam in the
future of Tolerance it wasn't called
Islam and the future of you know weapons
of mass destruction you know anyway well
it's an absolute pleasure I'm so glad we
connected and we're able to do this and
you're doing such great work
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me yeah so it's at Sarah the
hater on Twitter and everyone should
check out your group which is X Muslims
of North America and we're going to stay
in the loop and next time you know la
dinner is on
alright alright thanks a lot